[Música]
más de 24 horas después de la toma del
capitolio por parte de sus seguidores y
tras confirmarse una quinta muerte en
los hechos
donald trump suavizó su discurso aunque
sin aceptar propiamente su derrota en
las elecciones de noviembre reconoció
que una nueva administración tomara las
riendas del país el 20 de enero y se
comprometió a una transición ordenada y
tranquila
la pandemia de kobe 19 sigue azotando a
américa latina habrá 100 superó las
200.000 muertes y ross a los 8 millones
de casos confirmados mientras tanto
regresan los toques de queda y las
cuarentenas a la capital colombiana y el
ecuador ve como aumenta nuevamente los
contagios la región pone sus esperanzas
en un proceso de vacunación que será
mucho más lento que en los países ricos
en francia los restaurantes se
mantendrán cerrados al menos hasta
mediados de febrero cuando se suponía
que debían retomar sus actividades este
20 de enero en este informativo los
llevamos a parís donde conoceremos la
difícil situación que enfrenta uno de
los sectores más golpeados por la
pandemia
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 si revelan con gusto
saludarlos comenzamos un policía del
capitolio estadounidense sucumbió a sus
heridas y se convirtió en el quinto
fallecido tras la toma del legislativo
por parte de una turba de seguidores del
saliente presidente donald trump el
miércoles el mandatario devuelve un
mensaje en su cuenta de twitter la cual
había sido suspendida por publicar
mensajes incendiarios y por primera vez
no hablo de fraude electoral y se
comprometió a una transición tranquila
del poder esto ocurre en momentos en los
que crecen los llamados para que sea
removido del carro y cuando su gabinete
empieza a desintegrarse tras la renuncia
de la secretaria de transporte el hincha
o la secretaria de educación
betsy de osh andrés meza muñoz nos
cuenta más
donald trump suavizó el tono y por
primera vez acepto que habrá una nueva
administración sin mencionar que un
supuesto fraude en las elecciones le
arrebató su victoria como ha insistido
sin pruebas durante los últimos dos
meses ahora el congreso ha certificado
los resultados y la nueva administración
se inaugurará el 20 de enero mi enfoque
ahora se centra en garantizar una
transición de poder tranquila ordenada y
sin problemas su mensaje se dio a través
de su cuenta de twitter la cual había
sido suspendida por hacer publicaciones
incendiarias y en medio del repetido
llamado de congresistas demócratas e
incluso republicanos para que trump sea
removido de su cargo el mandatario ha
señalado de haber incitado al asalto
contra el capitolio el pasado miércoles
y aunque en otras ocasiones se negó a
condenar los actos de violencia
provocados por sus simpatizantes
esta vez calificó este acontecimiento
como un ataque atroz pero indignado por
la violencia de la anarquía y el caos
para aquellos que participaron en los
actos de violencia y destrucción
ustedes no representan en nuestro país y
para aquellos que violaron la ley usted
pagarán el aparente nuevo discurso de
trump llega a menos de dos semanas de
que finalice su mandato en los últimos
días no sólo ha crecido el número de
líderes republicanos que se niegan a
defenderlo sino también la lista de
funcionarios de su administración que
han optado por abandonar sus cargos
pasamos ahora américa latina donde el
año nuevo empieza con una situación
crítica por la pandemia en algunos
países pero así superó el jueves los
200.000 muertos a causa de este nuevo
coronavirus con dudas todavía sobre el
comienzo de la vacunación en colombia
las grandes ciudades optan por volver a
una cuarentena estricta y en el ecuador
los contagios se mantienen al alza el
informes de juán pupiales
más de 1500 muertos en un solo día es el
balance que habrá si el registro el
jueves y que lo lleva a romper una
barrera que hasta ahora sólo eeuu había
pasado más de 200.000 fallecidos son dos
caras de una misma moneda la de luto y
esta otra de las playas de río de
janeiro llenas en diciembre aquí al
igual que en otras grandes urbes como en
sao paulo belo horizonte la ocupación
hospitalaria ha llegado al 90%
recientemente ante ese panorama habló el
presidente ya aire bolsonaro un crítico
del aislamiento social y que insiste en
mantener la economía funcionando
esperamos volver a la normalidad tan
pronto como sea posible la vida continúa
hoy lamentamos que hayamos llegado a los
200 mil muertos muchos de ellos con kobe
otros de kobe pero la vida sigue lo
sentimos mucho un guay punto que el
ministro de salud espera que la
vacunación empiece antes del 20 de enero
y ya se anunció la compra de las
primeras dosis colombia un país vecino
espera comenzar esta vacunación desde
febrero pero antes el gobierno nacional
adoptó un toque de queda para el próximo
fin de semana
un lunes feriado que rige para aquellas
ciudades con una ocupación de unidades
de cuidados intensivos superior al 70
por ciento esto afectará a un tercio de
los aproximadamente 50 millones de
habitantes del país la restricción a la
venta de alcohol o ley seca es otra de
las medidas que ha sido adoptada de
manera independiente por algunas
ciudades con miras a que en estos días
que son siempre desafiantes desde el
punto de vista de la logística nacional
nosotros tengamos la menor presión
posible sobre la expansión del uso de
unidades de cuidado intensivo el jugador
por su parte lamenta por tercer día
consecutivo más de mil contagios de
covite 19 la nación rechazó prohibir el
ingreso de los viajeros del reino unido
por miedo a la nueva variante de covite
19 de este país espera que las primeras
50.000 dosis de la vacuna desarrollada
por fácil variante -que lleguen a partir
del 18 de enero y comenzará así este
proceso con adultos mayores y personal
sanitario
y la unión europea- aumenta de 300 a 600
millones las dosis compradas de la
vacuna pzifer bayón tec así lo indicó la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der layen según la funcionaria con
este acuerdo se aseguró vacunar a 380
millones de europeos lo que equivale a
más del 80 por ciento de la población
europea el anuncio de la extensión del
contrato con fisher by ontex dentro del
programa conjunto de vacunas de la
comisión europea se produce después de
varias polémicas a propósito de la
vacuna por supuestamente no adquirir
suficientes dosis del fármaco
en francia el primer ministro jan castex
anunció que los restaurantes
permanecerán cerrados al menos hasta
mediados de febrero en medio del aumento
de los casos de kobe 19 estaba previsto
que estos establecimientos pudieran
volver a ofrecer sus servicios a partir
del 20 de enero el sector es uno de los
más afectados por la crisis sanitaria
cerró sus puertas antes del primer
confinamiento y han sufrido más
restricciones incluso que el comercio
minoritario en nuestras periodistas
erika olavarría y el o ismael han nos
cuentan la difícil situación que
enfrenta a un joven empresario de la
restauración en parís
las hamburguesas son la especialidad del
restaurante caminito cabaré en el barrio
13 de parís y en tiempos de pandemia uno
de los pocos platos de su exigua carta
desde el 30 de octubre están cerrados y
sólo pueden vender para llevar
pese a ello el espíritu no decae ni
tampoco la afluencia fiel del público
es una forma de ayudar y además nosotros
tenemos que comer de todas maneras
elegimos los lugares que más nos gusten
hoy viene a tomar un examen presencial a
mis alumnos y aprovechamos para venir a
almorzar al mediodía como solíamos
hacerlo
veníamos seguido a este restaurante y es
una buena ocasión para apoyarlos en este
periodo como sea
los restaurantes en francia estuvieron
cerrados tres meses durante el primer
confinamiento y volvieron a cerrar el 30
de octubre pasado sin perspectivas de
pronta apertura los pocos que han
sobrevivido como el cabaré caminito de
aurelian lo hacen gracias a las ayudas
públicas
hace un año que sólo luchamos por
sobrevivir pasamos el día calculando
cómo hacer para que nuestra empresa no
se hunda la materia oscura la venta para
llevar es cool pero no es viable
económicamente no somos un fast food
no vamos a distribuir hasta altas horas
de la noche además nuestros precios son
más altos que los de la comida rápida
para redondear sus fines de mes aurelian
y su equipo tienen un puesto miércoles y
domingo en este mercado de barrio es una
iniciativa de la municipalidad de parís
y cada día experimentan diferentes
propuestas de minutos
no es fácil volverse experto en
panqueques como tampoco atravesar esta
crisis pero una buena dosis de humor
hace las cosas más fáciles
y cambiamos de información las
autoridades en indonesia liberaron al
líder religioso islamista ligado a los
atentados de bali se trata de abu bakar
bashir de 82 años que estaba condenado a
15 años de prisión pero obtuvo una
reducción de la pena por falta de
pruebas bakar bashir es considerado el
líder espiritual de la organización
islamista jemaah islamiyah responsable
de los atentados en bali en octubre de
2002 en los que murieron más de 200
personas entre ellas decenas de
australianos él siempre ha negado estar
implicado en estos ataques su liberación
generó indignación entre los cercanos a
las víctimas
hace que el informativo continúe con
nosotros buen día
[Música]
me muerdo los labios